Transcriber: Hager Muhammad
المدقّق: Ghada Khalil
هلا يفكر كل منكم ما هي أهم 10 مهارات لديه؟
أو أهم عشرين مهارة؟
أو أهم ثلاثين؟
أو سبعين؟
سأخبركم بمفاجأة.
يستطيع الإنسان على مدار حياته
أن يطور أكثر من 1341 مهارة.
أنا مثلكم لم أستطع الإجابة على سؤال
ما هي أهم 10 مهارات لدي
حين سُئلت عنها منذ 8 سنين،
وهذا السؤال غيَّر حياتي.
أول مقابلة أجريتها طُرح عليّ
سؤال يُطرح على كثيرين منا:
ما هي أهم 10 مهارات لديك؟
لكنني لم أستطع الإجابة عليه.
وبدأت أسأل نفسي بضعة أسئلة مثل:
لو كنت لا أعرف ما هي أهم 10 مهارات لدي،
ولا أعرف بم أهتم، أو ما الذي أريده
في حياتي، فمن ذا الذي يعرف؟
لو كنت لا أعرف شيئًا عن نفسي،
فمن الذي يدير حياتي إذن؟
عندما يُطرح علينا ذلك السؤال،
نجيب فورًا،
طبعًا أنا من أدير حياتي.
لكن إذا تمهلنا وفكرنا قليلاً،
سندرك أننا لسنا من ندير حياتنا.
ما تدير حياتنا عادةً
هي توقعات المجتمع،
وتعريفات الآخرين للنجاح،
وكثيرًا ما تديرها قرارات أهلنا.
أحيانًا تفرض وسائل الإعلام
علينا شكلاً معينًا للنجاح،
وتشير باستمرار إلى أنه
أسلوب الحياة الأمثل،
وتدعونا جميعًا إلى أن نحاول انتهاجه.
لكننا في الواقع لسنا من ندير حياتنا
لأننا لا نعرف شيئًا عن أنفسنا.
لا نستطيع أبدًا إدارة أي شيء
بدون أن نعرف عنه معلومات كافية.
أتدرون متى بدأ ذلك؟
بدأ منذ وُلدنا تقريبًا.
أنا متخصصة في علم النفس، لذا أعرف
أن أهم احتياج نفسي يُولد به الإنسان
هو احتياجه للحب والقبول من الآخرين.
نُولد ولدينا رغبة في الشعور بالانتماء
إلى الآخرين، والإحساس بحُبهم لنا.
لكن لأن من حولنا؛ المجتمع وأهلنا،
لديهم تعريف معين للحب،
يمنحوننا حبًا مشروطًا.
يفرضون علينا باستمرار خيارات معينة
مقابل أن يمنحوننا هذا الحب.
منذ طفولتنا يفرضون علينا
أن نشرب الحليب كي يحبوننا،
لذا نتعلم أننا إذا كنا نكره الحليب
لن نحصل على هذا الحب.
ويصل الأمر إلى أننا ندرس ونعمل
في مجالات يختارونها،
وننتهج أسلوب الحياة الذي يريدونه
كي نحصل على الحب والقبول منهم.
أتدرون كيف يؤثر ذلك علينا؟
يطمس صورتنا كما ترون هنا.
كل قرار يفرضه علينا أهلنا والمجتمع
يصيب شخصياتنا الحقيقية
التي خُلقنا بها بخدش جديد.
خُلقنا كهذا الشخص اللطيف المبتسم.
وهو لديه مجموعة من الإمكانيات
ينبغي أن تُوجه
كي يقوم بدور معين في الحياة.
لكنهم يطمسون شخصياتنا
بالقرارات التي يفرضونها علينا
كي يمنحوننا حبهم المشروط،
ونحن للأسف نحاول التكيف على ما يريده
المجتمع كي نحصل على ذلك الحب.
لكن بعدما نكبر،
ونكتشف أن الحياة لا تقتصر
على الدراسة وقرارات أهلنا،
ندرك احتياجًا نفسيًا آخر نُولد به كذلك.
الاحتياج إلى الإحساس بالإنجاز
وتقدير الذات.
نرى المجتمع والحياة يتغيران من حولنا،
ونود أن نكون جزءًا من هذا التغيير
لكننا لا نستطيع لأننا لا نعرف
ما هي إمكانياتنا
التي يمكنها مساعدتنا
في أن يكون لنا دور في ذلك التغيير.
وهنا تتبادر إلى أذهاننا بضعة أسئلة:
من أنا؟ ما الذي يناسبني؟
وهذا ما اكتشفته عندما بدأت
أدرس علم النفس منذ 8 سنين.
وبعدما انتهيت من دراسته،
تخصصت في مجال اسمه
الإرشاد والتوجيه المهني
Career Counseling.
هذا المجال لم يكن معروفًا
في مصر قبل 6 سنين.
وبدأت أدرس هذا المجال أساسًا
لأنني لم أكن على هدى في حياتي.
لم أعرف ماذا أفعل بعد تخرجي،
وما كنت أعرف ماذا أريد ولا من أنا.
كنت أشعر باستمرار أنني أتمتع
ببعض المميزات
لكنني كنت أتساءل أيضًا
عن ماهية هذه المميزات.
عندما بدأت أدرس ذلك المجال
في مؤسسة أمريكية
اكتشفت أنها بدأت منذ أكثر من 100 سنة
في تدريس ذلك المجال،
وأنه معروف في العالم كله.
طوال فترة عملي في الإرشاد المهني
قابلت عشرات العملاء الذين
يلجأوون إليّ لأنهم في حاجة
إلى أن يعرفوا ما الوظائف التي تناسبهم.
بعدما اكتسبت بعض الخبرة،
اكتشفت أن المشكلة ليست أن نعرف
الوظائف التي تناسبنا.
المشكلة الحقيقية هي أننا لا نعرف شخصياتنا.
المشكلة الحقيقية هي أننا لا نعرف
أي معلومة عن أنفسنا،
وبالتالي لسنا على هدى في حياتنا.
وهنا بدأت أتساءل
ما هي رسالتي في الحياة؟
وبعد أن عرفت نفسي جيدًا،
أدركت أن رسالتي في الحياة
هي أن أساعد كل فرد على أن يعرف مميزاته،
والصفات التي تميزه عمّن حوله
ولا تجعله نسخة من شخص آخر.
وهنا بدأ اهتمامي بفكرة الوعي الذاتي.
ما هو الوعي الذاتي؟
كل منا لديه شخصية تميزه عمّن حوله.
الشخصية عبارة عن مجموعة من السمات الشخصية.
مثل بصمات الأصابع،
فلكل منا بصمات أصابع مميزة
وتختلف تماماً عن بصمات أي شخص آخر.
الأمر نفسه ينطبق على شخصياتنا.
لا تشبه شخصية أي منا شخصية فرد آخر،
لكننا لا نلتفت لشخصياتنا المميزة
ونسعى إلى أن يكون كل منا نسخة من الآخر،
ولذلك لا نشعر بالسعادة
ولا ننجز أي شيء في حياتنا.
كيف أنمي وعيي الذاتي؟
سأطرح عليكم مثالاً.
كل منا لديه مجموعة من القيم؛
قيم تهمه وتدل على مسعاه في الحياة.
عملائي في جلسات الإرشاد المهني
مثال على ذلك.
إذا كان هناك شخص يعمل
خارج البلاد في وظيفة جيدة،
وأهله راضون عنها جدًا،
ويتقاضى راتبًا مجزيًا
يُتوقع طبقًا لمفهوم المجتمع عن النجاح
أن يكون راضيًا تمامًا عن حياته.
لكنه في الحقيقة ليس سعيدًا،
ما السبب في رأيكم؟
ليس سعيدًا لأنه لا يعرف القيم التي تهمه.
فبعد أن نساعده في تقييم شخصيته،
ومعرفة شخصيته الحقيقية،
نكتشف أنه من أهم القيم لدى ذلك الشخص
قيمة التأثير في الناس ومساعدتهم.
لكنه مشغول باستمرار في وظيفته الحسابية.
لذلك معرفتنا بالقيم التي تهمنا
هي أمر حيوي جدًا.
فإذا كانت العائلة قيمةً مهمةً بالنسبة لي،
لن يخطر ببالي أبدًا أن أعمل في الخارج
لأني أعرف أنني لن أكون سعيدةً
لو سافرت وعشت حياتي كلها بعيداً عن أهلي.
فينبغي أن نعرف القيم التي تهمنا؛
القيم التي تميزنا عن الآخرين،
لكنها لا تجعل أي منا أفضل من الآخر.
المهم أن أعرف القيم التي تهمني،
وابدأ في أن أعيش أسلوب حياة تلائمها.
من المهم أيضًا أن نعرف أنماط شخصياتنا.
لن تتصوروا قدر ما نواجهه في الجلسات
التي نخصصها للأطفال كي يكتشفوا شخصياتهم
من شكاوى من الأسر لأنهم يعتقدون
أن أطفالهم يعانون من مشكلة ما.
ما هي المشكلة؟ لدي ابن اجتماعي ويجيد
التعامل مع الناس ولديه كثير من الأصدقاء،
لكن ابني الآخر لديه صديقان أو ثلاثة فحسب.
وعندما نقيم شخصية ذلك الطفل،
نكتشف أنه انطوائي.
والأشخاص الانطوائيون هم من يفضلون
الانعزال بكتبهم في غرفهم،
أو يلعبون بمفردهم، وهذا كاف لإسعادهم.
لكن المجتمع يرى أن هذه مشكلة.
مجتمعنا يعتبر أولئك الأشخاص
غير الاجتماعيين لديهم مشكلة.
ونحاول باستمرار أن نجعلهم يتصرفون
على غير طبيعتهم ونشوه شخصياتهم
بدلاً من أن نحترم طابعهم الشخصي،
ونحاول أن ندعمهم ونطورهم.
من المهم أيضًا أن نعرف ما هي مهاراتنا.
كل منا لديه مجموعة من المهارات
إذا عرفها واستطاع تطويرها
سيكون مميزًا ولن يستطيع أحد القيام
بنفس عمله بالمهارة نفسها.
وعندما نعرف أنفسنا جيدًا نتقبلها أكثر.
سنستطيع تقبل أنفسنا في وقت
لا يستطيع أغلبنا تقريبًا فعل ذلك،
لذلك لا يشعرون بالثقة في أنفسهم.
يمكن أن يلجأ البعض إلى تدريبات
لتعزيز ثقتهم بأنفسهم،
لكننا عندما نتعامل معهم نكتشف
أنهم لا يتقبلون أنفسهم أساسًا
وبالتالي لا يشعرون بالثقة في أنفسهم.
عندما نعرف أنفسنا جيدًا،
نستطيع تقبلها بما فيها من عيوب.
بل لا نراها عيوبًا من الأساس.
ونرى أنها نتيجة لأشياء تُطلب منا
ولا تناسب شخصياتنا لذا يجب أن نتجنبها.
ومعرفتنا بأنفسنا تجعلنا أيضًا
قادرين على تقبل عيوبنا،
وتقبل ضعفنا.
هناك نوع آخر من الخدوش التي تصيب
شخصياتنا ويتسبب فيها أهلنا والمجتمع؛
وهي أنهم يعودوننا منذ صغرنا
على عدم التعبير عن أنفسنا
بدافع أن نكون أقوياء، ونعتمد على أنفسنا،
فلا يصح أن نعبر عن مشاعر الضعف في حياتنا.
وهذه هي أسوأ نصيحة يمكن أن يتبعها أي أحد.
عندما يعبر الإنسان عن مشاعر ضعفه،
يمنح نفسه فرصة أكبر
للاستفادة من الدروس التي يجب عليه تعلمها
من التجربة التي تعرض لها.
بالإضافة إلى أننا عندما نحاول التظاهر
بالقوة، نخسر أشياء أخرى في المقابل.
فلأننا نحاول الحفاظ على صورتنا القوية،
نحرص باستمرار على تجنب
خوض تجارب معينة
لأننا نخشى أن تنكسر صورتنا الذاتية القوية
أمام الآخرين.
وهذا يضيع علينا فرصة اكتساب خبرات
وخوض تجارب قد تغيَّر حياتنا.
لذا من المهم أن نبدأ في تدريب أنفسنا
على تقبل مشاعرنا،
والتعبير عن مشاعر الحزن والألم
على نحو طبيعي كمشاعر الفرح تمامًا.
التعبير عن مشاعر الحزن يجعلنا أيضًا
ندرك الدروس المستفادة
والرسائل المضمَّنة في تلك التجارب
التي يرسلها الله لنا،
لأن تلك التجارب لا تحدث
في حياتنا عشوائيًا.
عندما نعرف كل تلك الأمور عن أنفسنا،
نبدأ في الشعور بالرضا عن أنفسنا.
فعندما أعرف نفسي جيدًا وأتقبلها،
تُتاح لي فرصة تطويرها على نحو مختلف،
وبالطريقة التي تناسبني أنا.
بدلًا من محاولاتنا المستمرة
لنطوير مهارات لا نتمتع بها،
وبدلاً من أن نتعامل باستمرار
مع أمور لا تناسب شخصياتنا.
فكلما عمقنا معرفتنا بأنفسنا أكثر،
صرنا أكثر قدرة علي تطوير مهاراتنا الخاصة.
وهذا يقودنا إلى القدرة على إدارة الذات.
هكذا نستطيع إدارة حياتنا على نحو أفضل،
ونصبح متحكمين فيها.
حينئذ ندير حياتنا ونوجهها
لتحقيق أهدافنا الخاصة،
بدلاً من الأهداف التي كانت
تُفرض علينا باستمرار.
بعد أن مررت بتلك المراحل،
عرفت معنى السعادة.
السعادة التي تشبهني أنا.
منذ سنتين، بدأت أمارس تدريبًا اسمه
تحدي 100 يوم سعادة.
حينئذ كنت أمر بمرحلة صعبة جدًا في حياتي
إذ مررت بتجربة مؤلمة جدًا.
هذا التحدي مصمّم لمن لا يشعرون
بالسعادة في حياتهم،
وبالتالي عليهم خوضه كي يروا الحياة
من منظور مختلف.
هذا التحدي قامت به مؤسسة عالمية
هدفها هو أن تقول للناس
أنه في خضم حياتنا سريعة الإيقاع
والحافلة بالمشاغل،
يمكننا أن نجد السعادة.
وأن السعادة موجودة في أشياء بسيطة جدًا
في حياتنا،
وأن الأحداث الكبيرة ليست دائمًا
هي مصدر السعادة،
ورغم ذلك نركز عليها طوال الوقت
ولا نلاحظ الأشياء البسيطة الموجودة حولنا
والتي تسعدنا.
تحدي 100 يوم سعادة هدفه هو أن نبدأ بملاحظة
الأشياء البسيطة التي تسعدنا يوميًا،
ونبدأ بمشاركة تلك الفكرة مع الناس
لكي نلهم أشخاصًا آخرين بخوض ذلك التحدي
لكي يروا الحياة من منظور مختلف.
عندما بدأت ذلك التحدي منذ سنتين
أو سنة وعدة أشهر تقريبًا،
اكتشفت أن هناك أمور
في غاية البساطة تسعدني.
اكتشفت أنني عندما أخرج مع أهلي
أشعر بالسعادة.
بالرغم من أنني كنت أحيانًا أخرج معهم
وأحيان أخرى لا أستطيع
لأنني مشغولة بعملي وأود تحقيق أهدافي
في سيرتي العملية.
ومع اهتمامي بتلك الأمور البسيطة،
أجد أن رغبتي في إنجاز أهداف بعينها تتحقق.
فمنذ سنة تقريبًا، تمنيت إلقاء محادثة
في TEDx عن الوعي الذاتي،
وبالمصادفة تحقق ذلك منذ شهر.
اكتشفت أيضًا أن من الأمور البسيطة
التي تسعدني
هي أن أقضي يومي في قراءة كتبي
وأستمتع بشرب القهوة.
هذا يسعدني للغاية.
اكتشفت أن اهتمامي بصحتي يسعدني،
فبدأت أمارس الرياضة
وصارت جزءًا من أسلوب حياتي.
اكتشفت أنني كنت أفعل أشياءً كثيرة
لا تسعدني،
واكتشفت أنني عندما أغير تصفيفة شعري
أشعر بالسعادة
واكتشفت أن أكثر ما يسعدني
هو أن أقابل أحد العملاء
الذين عملت معهم في السنوات الماضية،
ويقول لي: "شكرًا لك، فاليوم اتخذت قرارًا
يناسب قيمي الشخصية"،
"اليوم اخترت خيارات تشبهني أنا"،
صرت أعرف نفسي أكثر، وهذا حقق لي السعادة.
هذه الأمور لفتت نظري إلى بعض الأشياء.
جعلتني أدرك أن كل شخص منا
تسعده أمور بعينها تناسبه،
وتختلف عن الأمور التي تسعد أي شخص آخر.
أدركت أن السعادة هي أن يتصرف
كل فرد على طبيعته،
ويصبح أفضل نسخة من نفسه
بدلاً من أن يتنافس باستمرار
مع آخرين على تقليد شخص آخر.
كل تلك التجربة حدثت
خلال الثماني سنوات الماضية،
فلماذا بدأت أفكر فيها الآن؟
بدأت أفكر فيها لأنني أتممت
عامي الثامن والعشرين في هذا الشهر.
في ذكرى ميلادي أو قبلها بقليل،
كنت منزعجة جدًا،
كنت أرفض أن يكلمني أي أحد عن ذلك
أو يذكرني به، ووددت أن أعود لسن العشرين.
لكن عندما استرجعت ما حدث لي في حياتي،
وبدأت في تأمل أحداثها وربطها ببعضها،
اكتشفت أن تلك السنوات الثمانية
كانت الأهم في حياتي.
أحدثت فارقًا كبيرًا في حياتي لأنني صرت
أعرف كيف أسعد نفسي بنفسي،
وهذا أفضل معنى للسعادة.
يُقال باستمرار أن من لا يستطيع
تحقيق السعادة مع نفسه،
لا يستطيع تحقيقها في علاقاته وعمله،
وهذا حقيقي فعلاً.
كلما بذلنا مجهودًا أكبر واستثمرنا
طاقتنا في إسعاد أنفسنا بأنفسنا،
كي نتقبلها، بدلاً من أن ننتقدها
وننفر منها،
صرنا أقدر على بلوغ السعادة.
اليوم أنا فخورة جدًا
لأن منذ 6 سنوات لم يكن هناك أحد
يساعد الناس على معرفة أنفسهم أكثر،
بينما كنت أنا سببًا في أن يصبح
هذا المجال أو التخصص
موجودًا في مصر، ويساعد مئات الأشخاص
في أن يعرفوا أنفسهم أكثر ويغيروا حيواتهم.
لم يعد اهتمام الناس موجه
إلى جمع قدر أكبر من المال،
والالتحاق بإحدى كليات القمة،
وتقلد منصب عملي معين.
أسمع باستمرار أشخاصًا
يقولون أن هدفهم في الحياة
هو أن يشعروا بالسعادة،
وأنهم مهتمون فعلاً بأن يفهموا أنفسهم.
أكثر شيء يسعدني هو أن يقول لي أحد عملائي:
"آية، اليوم سأخوض تجربة جديدة
كي أكتشف نفسي."
هذه هي كل الأمور التي علينا
أن نتوقف للتفكير بها،
ونحاول أن نعرفها عن أنفسنا،
ولن يكون هناك أي داع للقلق بعد ذلك.
إذا عرفتم أنفسكم جيدًا،
ستعرفون ما الوظائف التي تناسبكم.
ستبنون علاقاتكم على نحو أصح،
وستعيشون حياة أفضل.
وستنجحون في أمر نتمنى جميعًا تحقيقه؛
وهو أنكم ستغيرون القوالب الحياتية
التي حددها المجتمع للناس كي ينجحوا.
تدفعنا أسرنا باستمرار لانتهاج
أساليب معينة لتحقيق النجاح
لأنهم لا يعرفون سوى تلك الأساليب.
يظنون أنه ليس هناك أساليب أخرى
سواها لتحقيق النجاح.
لكن إذا استطعنا بوعينا الذاتي
خلق نماذج جديدة للنجاح،
سنغير قوالب النجاح التي حددها المجتمع،
وستتوافر نماذج أخرى أكثر.
وسنعطي فرصة للأجيال القادمة
عندما تريد أن تفعل شيئًا مختلفًا،
أن تواجه الرفض بأن هناك
من فعل الشيء ذاته ممن سبقوهم.
هذه هي الرسالة التي نحتاج
ان نركز جميعًا عليها
كي نعيش حياة سعيدة، ولنكون أفرادًا منتجين،
ونشعر بالإنجاز.
وعندما نعرف أنفسنا جيدًا،
نستطيع تقديمها للناس بأسلوب أفضل،
وهكذا سيحبون شخصياتنا الحقيقية
لا النسخ المزيفة منها التي صنعوها.
شكرًا لكم.
(تصفيق)